after surviving weeks of fighting in
Sudan's capital cartoon Sana Mahmoud
made it to this shelter in wadihalfa on
the border with Egypt
from there she traveled not to this camp
in Cairo along with her two daughters
she's now safe from the violence at home
which she says memories of the gunfire
and asteroids continue to haunt her
girls
my daughter saw everything the gunfire
was falling on us at home they saw
horrible scenes my younger daughter
still screams at night and cries out to
me why are these people coming to kill
us
Olympic
Mahmoud describes how her daughter would
run in fear when she heard fighter jets
overhead in cartoon
when she sees the plane she comes
running saying mom the plane has come
Mom these people are coming for us at
home they're coming to beat us I tell
her that the plane is just flying and is
not targeting us
hundreds of thousands of children in
Sudan have similar experiences the un's
children's agency UNICEF says the
violence has worsened existing problems
with this crisis with this conflict we
have seen a nationwide closure of
schools and educational institutions
already we were talking about seven
million kids out of school 12 million
somehow in schools but very disruptive
learning over the last couple of years
particularly in the last year when it
had due to teachers rights and school
closures across the country
the agency says fighting has forced
nearly 370 000 children from their homes
and an estimated 190 children were
killed in the first 10 days of the
conflict
at this Center in Port Sudan the sound
of gunfire is replaced with music and
dance where a group of artists has
organized activities for children
thousands of families have been coming
here in the hope of leaving Sudan
through its Red Sea port
experts say witnessing bombardment first
hand has taken a devastating toll on
people here
we have a number of cases for children
who have post-traumatic stress disorder
who are transferred to the psychiatric
hospital we also have similar cases
among adults the thing that we can do
now for the children is support them and
alleviate the bad psychological impacts
on them
children are often the most at risk when
conflicts happen and Sudan is no
exception now millions of families have
no choice but to wait and see what
happens next